hey youtubers is Charlie so this is
gonna be my agents of shield episode 8
video we also got some big news about
some stuff Marvel is doing with the
Netflix series as well as stuff that's
going on on agents of show so all I had
the news to that so biggest news first
we found out which lead actors Marvel is
testing for the leads in both Jessica
Jones and the Luke Cage Netflix series
for Jessica Jones
it's Alexandra Daddario from True
detective and Percy Jackson Jessica de
Gouw who we all know and love is the
Huntress on arrow
Krysten Ritter who you might remember
from Breaking Bad and Teresa Palmer from
warm bodies for Luke Cage they're
testing Lance Goss from Good Wife and
Mike Colter from the following I will
totally do separate videos for them
after agents of shield is over like
after the mid-season finale but Jessica
Jones will premiere first Luke Cage is
supposed to be in six or seven episodes
of that and then he'll move to his own
series so it'll be Jessica Jones then
Luke Cage supposedly they're gonna try
and finish Jessica Jones before the end
of 2015 that's their goal daredevil of
course is almost done filming no release
date for that yet but that'll probably
spring or summer next year I'll say
Alexandra Daddario is probably the
favorite for Jessica Jones right now the
news about shield is a little bit
spoilery they just confirmed some
details so I'll just talk about that
during my top 5 moments speaking which
careful for spoilers in case you haven't
seen this week's episode so starting
with top five moments number five Hydra
flashbacks this whole episode was more
of a Hydra episode in general which I
totally love with a giant red skull
shout out may he rest in peace even
though he's not dead
technically we don't spend a whole lot
of time telling stories from their
perspective even Winter Soldier only
flirted with the idea and it was like a
hundred fifty million dollar Hydra movie
doctor Whitehall takes center stage and
we watch the horror of his World War two
experiments trying to figure out the
diviner if he didn't notice her this
special guest star that turned out to be
Skye's mother by the way was a fellow
Whedon verse' lump from dollhouse her
name's Deacon Lachman the funny thing is
is that Reed diamond was also on
dollhouse so this is like a mini
dollhouse mini Goss Whedon reunion
happening on screen anytime he watched
shield just keep your eyes peeled for
actors that have started another Joss
Whedon productions they always cast
Whedon verse alums all the time
the minute she showed up I knew she was
gonna be someone special just because I
recognized her but I was really
surprised by the fact she turned out to
be Skye's mother I feel like that was
the bigger reveal all that Whitehall
stuff in the past also served as the
tie-in for the
Peggy Carter plot with another great
cameo number for Team Coulson searches
for the city so like all the good guys
took a backseat to the Hydra stuff they
still did get a few big reveals from
their perspective the first one being
that that base that they've been using
all year is the original Peggy Carter
base that means that whenever the Peggy
Carter TV series premieres in January it
might also take place at this base I
don't have any confirmation on that but
it makes sense that they would use the
same set to try and save money
they'll just redress it so it looks like
it did during the original Captain
America movie you know world war ii era
i have no idea what the actual plot of
the Peggy Carter TV show is gonna be but
it makes sense that they would try and
connect it to the future if they've been
spending all this time on agents of
shield trying to connect it back to
Peggy Carter the only thing that's been
confirmed about her TV show is some of
the actors we don't know who the big
villains gonna be yet fingers crossed
for Baron Zemo but I don't think it's
gonna happen so team Coulson not even
gonna bother trying to get the diviner
back they're just gonna go to the finish
line and Park it till Hydra gets there
that's what's gonna be happening in the
mid-season finale like they'll have the
big battle probably have some sort of
reveal of the city don't know how far
they'll push into it though I expect a
lot of that to take place in the back
half of the season
number three Ward vs. brother Ward since
turning him into Hydra Ward has just
gotten so much more fun I really like
Brett Dalton as an actor but quarterback
Ward from season one was barely a
character Hydra Ward so much better
in fact agents of shield season one is
hitting Netflix this Thursday so if you
never watch that you can actually watch
it now but season two just a general way
better because he's been so evil this
season it's been hard to tell whether or
not he was telling the truth about
killing his younger brother the episode
was called things we bury so the well
was nice connective tissue to Peggy
Carter burying Whitehall in a prison the
whole thing reminded me of Marvel's
original sin storyline from this year
horrible things from everyone's past
coming back to haunt them if you haven't
read that it's totally awesome you
should check it out so if you were
confused by that final scene it was a
bit of a time jump so what I think
happened is is that Ward really did kill
his brother and his family then went to
see Whitehall it is possible that he
secretly saved his brother and faked the
fire I don't think that's the case but
it's hard to tell how they're gonna
redeem Ward's character if they intend
to do that at all he keeps going from
bad to worse so I don't know that there
is any redemption for him at this point
we'll see it's gonna take some major act
it's kind of like he is the Winter
Soldier of Coulson's team not super evil
but not a good character either by far
the biggest thing I'm looking forward to
with Ward's character is this three-way
alliance that they have going on inside
Hydra just think about the idea of a
Hydra like a mythical Hydra eating its
own heads just think about that metaphor
and what might happen with these
villains we do not absolutely go nuts if
Skye's father turned into a real monster
and literally bit off Whitehall's head
number two Skye's father explained so we
finally learned what's going on with
Kyle McLaughlin on the show he's Skye's
father Whitehall killed his wife so when
he went to see Whitehall he was just
trying to get close to him so he could
destroy him from the inside it gets a
little complicated but just remember he
said I have nothing to lose so it's not
that he wants to help Coulson it's just
that he wants his daughter back and he
wants to be reunited with his wife in
the afterlife
that's pretty ambiguous so there are a
number of different ways to go with this
the thing that you guys should really
look forward to though is that producers
confirm that they would be fully
exploring Skye's family relationship
before the end of season 2 as in across
the back half of the seasons so it's not
like Kyle MacLachlan it's not gonna be
around the back half of the season of
all the characters in the show he seems
like the only one that has a real clue
what's going on with the Inhumans with
this mystery city and my number one WTF
moment of course doctor Whitehall
explained for those that were asking me
on Twitter here's what I think that
Whitehall did to Skye's mother he said
he took everything he could
quote-unquote everything that probably
means he harvested all our internal
organs any blood plasma liquids or any
special inhuman organic parts that he
found so now I can mention that other
big thing that the producers confirmed
they said the blue tahiti alien was Kree
that to me is the strongest evidence for
Inhumans that we could ever get for
those that haven't read the comics the
Inhumans were created by the Kree
thousands of years ago Kree scientists
traveled to the earth to turn humans
into a weaponized army to use in their
ongoing war with the Skrulls
so the Inhumans were originally meant to
be used as weapons against the Kree but
things went sideways and they were left
on their own for a long time
cut to thousands of years later in
modern day we now have the royal family
that we've seen in the comics Black Bolt
Medusa all those characters were born in
the last
as a result of careful selective
breeding all this went on in the secret
city of Attilan which i think is the
secret city that Coulson's looking for
Marvel is making an Inhumans movie in a
couple years and suddenly everything is
connected Skye's mother probably an
inhuman making Skye an inhuman
which is why they're able to touch the
diviner don't worry though all those
questions will be answered next week
just to reiterate though even if we do
see super-powered Inhumans on agents of
shield I don't think we'd ever see the
royal family that's like Black Bolt
Medusa you get the idea there plug in to
save those characters for the movies
Plus none of them have even been cast
yet even though there's a rumor that Vin
Diesel might be Black Bolt so Skye's
father says some really important things
about what's gonna happen inside that
city here's what I think is going on
he said the diviner has something inside
it could be a Terrigen crystal he said
that someone special had to carry it
into a temple in the city so I think if
Skye were to carry the diviner into said
temple she'd activate her inhuman powers
I've seen a theory that she could be
Daisy Johnson from the comics aka quake
and she get earth-shaking powers in the
comics that character had a father named
mr. Hyde that looks kind of like Skye's
father that did similar experiments to
him it's just the best theory I've seen
so far I feel like everything in the
show has been building towards Skye
getting special powers but let me know
what was your favorite moment from the
episode and here's my big question for
you guys do you feel like this is all
part of an Inhumans plot and do you
think that that city is gonna turn out
to be at Illin
overall I gave the episode a B+ loved
the Hydra side of the story but I felt
like the Coulson shield side was not
able to match the energy you know yes
Tripp almost dying was a big deal but
characters having sex in the back of a
car will not hold a candle to harvesting
organs all the actors of course totally
amazing Brett Dalton definitely on his
a-game Kyle MacLachlan appropriately
crazy cannot wait to see more of him
being nuts he is one of the best actors
at playing someone who's just a little
bit crazy Reed diamond is Whitehall
still a little bit of a mystery I really
want the show to spend some more time
with him he's an amazing actor but he
just hasn't been featured on screen that
much so far just in general I feel like
Shield has become way more interesting
since season 1 they have a clear villain
who I think is dr. Whitehall with a lot
of ambiguous villains like Skye's father
and neutral Loki type characters like
Ward I will try and do some more Marvel
Universe in humor
bonus videos before the finale next week
so be sure to subscribe to get that
stuff feel free to make requests for
bonus videos too I will be doing Peggy
Carter videos every week for all those
episodes that starts January 6th and
like I said I'll do more bonus videos
for the Netflix shows whatever shield
goes on break just cuz I'll have a
little bit more time and just some
really good news if you haven't seen me
explain in my other videos YouTube is
letting me test out some new beta
features so I have new links if you're
watching on your mobile phone or your
tablet you can click on the links that I
always add over here up here these links
will always be the same too so you can
click here to catch up on agents of
shield and you can click here to learn
all about the Inhumans movie thank you
so much for watching so let's all
high-five I'll see you guys tonight
you